the fbi raided trump's house in
mar-a-lago well the fbi executed his
search warrant and took a bunch of
documents and things but
yes this is unprecedented in america yes
it could be the beginning of a criminal
prosecution of the former president
yes it could be the tip of the spear of
a political witch hunt by the biden
administration against a political rival
or it could be a mundane effort to
retrieve archival documents that leads
to absolutely nothing else we just don't
know the fbi and i give them a lot of
credit because they're fighting forces
that they're not supposed to be fighting
but what do we know about the search
warrant that was carried out against
former president trump we can't make
many assumptions about the fbi raid
until we see the actual warrant or until
you know we see an indictment but here's
what we do know the justice department
is conducting at least two
investigations that we know of into
trump the doj is looking at his attempt
to overturn the result of the 2020
presidential election and is also
investigating the alleged mishandling of
classified records the national archive
is charged with collecting and sorting
presidential material the national
archives has publicly stated that it had
to recover at least 15 boxes of white
house records that trump took to his
mar-a-lago resort the records include
some classified material and we know
that trump has a history of destroying
and withholding records he was
repeatedly warned about destroying
documents but according to cnn politico
and the washington post he tore them up
and threw them in the trash or on the
floor white house officials reassembled
some of those records with tape the
national archives confirmed that the
trump administration sent the archives
some documents that had been taped back
together as well as records that were
still in shreds i'll be doing a separate
video on the presidential records act
and the implications of the espionage
act but multiple sources told cnn that
in april and may the fbi interviewed
trump's mar-a-lago aides and in june of
2022 investigators visited mar-a-lago to
discuss trump's removal of potentially
classified material that had been taken
to the florida property one of those
investigators jay bratt is the chief of
the counterintelligence and export
control section at the justice
department trump reportedly greeted the
investigators but did not answer
questions the investigators asked to see
where the documents were being stored
trump's lawyers showed them a room in
the basement where boxes of records were
being stored some reports said that the
documents were marked with top secret
on june 8 the investigators sent a
letter to trump's lawyers telling them
to secure the room where the secret
documents were stored trump aides
complied with the request and added a
padlock to the door now i probably don't
need to tell you just how insane it is
that there could be top secret
classified documents being stored in
some basement in mar-a-lago uh or just
how insane it is that the fbi raided the
mar-a-lago potentially over these
documents but i do have to say that uh
they even broke into my safe is probably
going to go down
as a quote for the ages but the search
began early monday morning and
apparently focused on the area of the
club where trump's offices and personal
quarters are located the investigators
met with two of trump's attorneys and
trump reportedly greeted the
investigators but did not answer
questions investigators removed more
than a dozen boxes of items eric trump
told fox news that he was told the
purpose of the raid from what they said
was because national archives wanted to
you know corroborate whether or not
donald trump had any documents in his
possession trump's lawyer christina todd
said the fbi seized documents and trump
cooperated with the fbi quote president
trump and his legal team have been
cooperative with the fbi and doj
officials every step of the way the fbi
did conduct an unannounced raid and
seized paper though the bob said that
the raid was unannounced cnn reported
the fbi and secret service communicated
about the raid before it happened to
ensure that it went smoothly donald
trump was in new york on the day of the
raid and the biden administration was
reportedly not aware of the raid
according to cnn now we can assume this
raid did not happen at the behest of a
rogue fbi agent or a local judge acting
without buy-in or notification of
high-level doj officials obviously
serving a warrant on a former president
is an incredibly serious thing and it's
a decision that can't be taken lightly
the fbi and doj must follow
constitutional and statutory
requirements for obtaining a warrant
which we'll talk about in a moment but
in addition the doj has guidelines for
investigations of political targets in
2020 former attorney general william
barr issued a controversial memorandum
stating that anyone in the justice
department who was investigating a
political candidate must run it by the
attorney general for approval and
current attorney general merrick garland
renewed that memo on may 25 2022
garland's memo is titled election year
sensitivities the memo reminded doj
employees of the department's
long-standing policy for avoiding steps
that could be perceived as partisan and
designed to influence uh an election
result quote this is particularly
important in an election year now that
the 2022 election season is upon us and
as in prior election cycles i am using
this memorandum to remind you of the
department's existing policies with
respect to political activities now
barr's original memo says investigations
including preliminary ones into
presidential or vice presidential
candidates their campaigns or staff
cannot be opened without the written
approval of the attorney general it also
states that an investigation into a
congressional candidate or campaign
cannot be opened without first notifying
the assistant attorney general and the
respective u.s attorney in the district
involved and if an investigation is
initiated in line with these guidelines
then the investigating agency has to
provide regular updates to the deputy
attorney general now trump has indicated
that he will be a candidate for
president in 2022. so the tldr version
here is the fbi would not have applied
for a search warrant without garland's
consent and presumably they also would
have gotten approval from the trump
appointed fbi director christopher wray
but what is the requirement for a
federal search warrant well a search
warrant authorizes law enforcement to
search a location for any of the
following evidence of a crime contraband
fruits of crime or other items illegally
possessed
property designed for use intended for
use or used in committing a crime or a
person to be arrested or a person who
was unlawfully restrained now usually
those first three are lumped together
imagine a simple burglary where jewelry
was stolen you'd want to look at the
burglar's house for the stolen jewelry
cash or drugs that might have been
traded for the stolen jewelry or
burglary tools and so law enforcement
has to identify two different things one
the person or property to be searched
and two the items to be seized now more
to the point law enforcement has to
establish probable cause to believe that
the items to be seized exist and will be
located in the person or property to be
identified and probable cause is hard to
define it's imprecise fluid and very
dependent on context the u.s supreme
court says that finding whether probable
cause exists is quote a practical common
sense decision whether given all the
circumstances there is a fair
probability that contraband or evidence
of a crime will be found in a particular
place and what does fair probability
actually mean well it doesn't have a
specific number attached to it unlike
the standard of preponderance of the
evidence which is just a hair over 50 or
more that said several studies over the
decades that involve surveys of judges
generally agree the probable cause is
somewhere in the high 40s but beneath 50
and it might be worth noting that some
jurisdictions like oregon have collapsed
the probable cause standard and the
preponderance standard so that probable
cause means anything over 50 likelihood
but that is not the federal or
constitutional standard the
constitutional standard is only a fair
probability now you might ask how
specific does a federal search warrant
have to be well generally speaking not
that specific we can look to the search
warrant that was used against paul
manafort it includes something very
specific quote a bichon black titanium
royal whey watch but it also includes
general categories of items like any and
all financial records for paul manafort
jr now we'll get into what that means in
practice later but let's talk about the
practice for getting a federal search
warrant now the applicant for a search
warrant is generally a federal law
enforcement officer of some kind an fbi
agent a treasury agent et cetera
and as of 2016 federal agencies employed
about 132 000 full-time law enforcement
officers and every federal search
warrant is reviewed by an assistant u.s
attorney of some kind now that's not
required by law but it's a policy
decision by the department of justice
now the application itself is a one-page
template and federal law enforcement
generally attaches three documents to
that application the first is the
affidavit by the investigating officer
attachment a includes the property to be
searched and attachment b lists uh the
items to be seized now the affidavit is
a sworn declaration by the law
enforcement officer that sets forth the
officer's knowledge of the investigation
it can include hearsay and even
information from anonymous or
confidential sources though the officer
needs to establish the reliability of
that information the purpose of that
affidavit is to establish probable cause
to the reviewing magistrate but the
affidavit is all there is the magistrate
does not get to consider any additional
information just what's contained within
the four corners of that document now
that said the magistrate judge has to
issue the warrant if there is probable
cause it's not optional the judge does
not have discretion to say well there is
probably probable cause but i don't
think you need it for your investigation
it's looking pretty good on its own
once the magistrate judge has found
probable cause the warrant must issue
and what this means in practice is that
the magistrate judge signs the
application the one-page template and
issues it to another officer authorized
to execute it the warrant must be
executed within 14 days and during the
day time unless there's good cost to
execute it at some other time and this
should go without saying but i'm gonna
say it again anyway just because a judge
signs off on it doesn't mean a crime has
been committed and just because you have
received a federal search warrant
doesn't mean that you are a criminal or
have done really anything wrong
see contra all of the legal bad takes on
twitter and as a reminder
just because a search warrant was
executed on a particular person's
property that doesn't mean that
particular person is the target of an
investigation now it is very common for
that to be the case but search warrants
are frequently served on google and meta
for information and data that they keep
on their servers that are relevant to an
investigation they're not the target of
that investigation now and it's rare but
occasionally search warrants are
executed on members of the media who
have information or lawyers who
represent the targets of an
investigation nor does it mean there
absolutely will be a prosecution just
because there is probable cause doesn't
mean that the government can prove a
case beyond a reasonable doubt in a jury
trial that's a completely separate
consideration in light of all the
evidence including
whatever evidence comes out as a result
of the search warrant the beyond
reasonable doubt standard is much much
higher than the probable cause or even
the preponderance of the evidence
standard though it's always good to
remind people that just because you
aren't convicted beyond a reasonable
doubt doesn't mean you didn't commit a
crime also you know so it goes both ways
now there are some differences between
state and federal courts when it comes
to search warrants for one the states
don't have a single uniform procedure
like the federal courts do now they all
basically get you to the same place but
they certainly won't look as uniform as
they do in the federal system and state
judges have a reputation for rubber
stamping applications for search
warrants the federal system uh has the
department of justice that acts as a
gatekeeper for search warrants even
though that's not required by federal
law so state judges are more likely to
get warrants to contain plenty of
grammatical and formatting issues and
might not have quite as much uh evidence
as far as probable cause goes but in any
event the end result is that officers
will show up to a location knocking on
the door notifying the people inside of
the search warrant and then searching
the scene that means getting everyone
out of the place so that they can't
tamper with evidence or present a threat
the officers then search the place in
accordance with what's allowed in the
warrant they can search for the items
authorized by the warrant and open any
containers that could reasonably contain
the items including safes block boxes
and the like and using the paul manafort
search warrant as an example
we saw that there was a pretty big
category any and all financial records
for paul manafort jr so let's say that
you're one of the fbi agents on the
scene you would basically look for
documents and papers and let's say that
you find a manila folder that contains
100 or so pages you might skim through
it and as you do you see a couple of
financial records that pertain to paul
manafort you would then likely seize the
entire manila folder there are two
reasons for this one
people typically keep financial records
with other financial records or related
records and those related records might
be needed to make sense of the specific
financial records that they're kept with
and second you don't have time at the
scene to fully understand how all the
documents link together in other words
you don't understand the import of those
documents at the scene so you'd probably
take the entire manila folder and notate
on an inventory form something like
manila folder containing financial
documents located in the lower
right-hand desk drawer in the office now
agents keep an inventory of what items
they seize and where they found those
items they are required by law to do
this when they're done executing the
search warrant they will leave a copy of
the search warrant as well as a copy of
the inventory of things seized now it's
important to note
they do not leave a copy of the
affidavit all they will leave is the one
page application along with the two
attachments listing the property to be
searched and the items to be seized
after that the investigating officers
would then return the search warrant to
the magistrate and it would specify the
date and time the warrant was executed
and include the inventory of item seized
so what's next well trump has a copy of
the search warrant but not the
supporting affidavit he could release it
if he chose to there's no legal reason
why he couldn't release it
and it's interesting that he has chosen
not to and additionally there are
reports of a mole or informant inside of
mar-a-lago which might explain the
exigency of the fbi search of mar-a-lago
additionally the florida times union
judicial watch and the new york times
have filed a motion to unseal the
records the supporting affidavit is
sealed to protect the investigation and
generally the doj doesn't comment on
ongoing investigations because it could
jeopardize the investigation and tip off
other targets or the target who is the
initial target 12 seconds later except
of course when the doj chooses that it's
going to make a statement about an
ongoing investigation like when you're
trying to get a freaking youtube video
out and the attorney general for the
united states chooses to give a press
conference
attorney general merrick garland
confirmed in a press conference that
indeed he did have personal supervision
over the search warrant that was
executed over the former president's
estate at mar-a-lago and in fact because
former president trump did confirm the
search warrant was executed and publicly
stated information about it the doj is
going to move to unseal the records
related to the the search warrant itself
one gets the sense that the doj was
trying to keep this quiet and in fact
this comes on the heels of a report from
the new york times that
a subpoena was issued against former
president trump to return
some or all of the documents in question
and that may have not been complied with
which might have forced the doj's hand
to execute a search warrant to get these
documents and now we're facing the
incredibly interesting situation where
it's the doj that is moving to disclose
this information
and it may be former president trump who
doesn't want it disclosed he of course
always had the ability to disclose uh
the receipt and the the other pages of
the warrant uh other than the the
probable cause affidavit and now he may
be in a situation where he wants to keep
that secret but at least that's likely
to be the last bombshell that we have to
deal with in this particular case for a
while 12 seconds later are you freaking
kidding me so the washington post is now
reporting that the documents at issue
here uh concern nuclear weapons uh which
explains a whole lot about why this
search warrant was executed uh why the
exiting circumstances um and why
everyone is freaking out uh it also
throws a huge curveball in the people
that were saying that the president
could just declassify documents on the
way out of the white house when it comes
to nuclear weapons related documents
often that has to go through a separate
regulatory agency often the the
president is in charge of
declassification but when it comes to
these kinds of documents that is not
necessarily the case uh it also raises
all kinds of questions as to why former
president trump took these documents out
of the white house and why he might have
refused to turn them back over uh when
multiple requests were made which is
what has been alleged uh so we'll uh
we'll cover all of the potential
criminal implications of this in a
separate video
but this whole situation is raising all
kinds of questions but one thing is for
sure keeping a bunch of classified
documents in a basement would be a
pretty stupid move but they could
quickly get their brains back to
functioning correctly with a logic or
math course from today's sponsor
brilliant brilliant is an online
learning platform for stem that replaces
lecture videos with hands-on interactive
lessons brilliant is for curious
learners both young and old professional
and inexperienced you could quickly
learn to ace your high school or college
math courses or just learn stuff you
always wanted to one of my favorite
courses is all about logic brilliance
logic courses cover
liar and truth teller riddles logical
fallacies machine logic and even some
strategic game theory and logic is a
crucial skill that lawyers
and former presidents need every day
brilliant statistics and finance classes
are also extraordinary now brilliant
lets you learn by doing rather than just
listening to hours of boring lectures
learning through doing is scientifically
proven to be the most effective way to
master any new skill the courses have
storytelling interactive challenges and
problems to solve so you can sign up and
start learning today for free by
clicking on the link that's on screen
right now or in the description the
first 200 people to sign up will also
get 20 off their annual subscriptions so
by clicking on the link that's on screen
near the description you'll get 20 off
your subscription to brilliant plus
clicking that link really helps out this
channel and after that click on this
playlist for more illegal eagle or i'll
see you in court